numbers of lives probably on
both sides.
>> Sam, thank you for joining
us in Kyiv.
Boris Townsend says that the
Russian president Vladimir
Putin was personally threatened
him with a missile.
The former British prime
minister said it happened
during a phone call before
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
last year.
The exchange was release as a
preview to the bbc documentary,
Putin versus the west.
Here is how Johnson described
it.
>> He sort of threatened me at
one point, and said, Boris, I
don't hurt you, but with a
missile Italy take a minute or
something like that.
Jolly.
But I think, from the very
relaxed tone that he was taking,
the sort of Arabs attachment
that he seemed to have.
He was just playing along with
my attempts to get into
negotiate.
>> Well the Kremlin is
responding to that accusation.
CNN's Clare Sebastian joins
now.
I think portions is making the
point that it was not a direct
threat of assassination.
It was a power play, right?
>> That's what he was saying.
The Kremlin is flatly denying
it.
They say the portions was live
in, but there were no missile
threats, and they said this is
according to the spokesperson
Dimitri press cough, that the
only mentioned came in the
context of Putin expresses
concern that if Ukraine would
join nato, that would mean the
potential for U.S. And nato
missiles to be placed along the
border with the potential to of
course hit inside Russia's
territory.
So they're saying that there is
no actual missile threat,
because no missiles were
mentioned.
In terms of what we do know,
there was a call, it was last
call between Johnson and Putin,
before the war, we don't know
for sure that is the one they
were referring, to but it seems
likely that they did mention
nato.
President Putin expresses
worried that the alliance was
not taking Russia's concerns --
>> This is the official?
Readout >> Yes.
The official one says that
Putin was concerned that they
were meeting their demands, and
more shots and it's forcing Lee
says that he believed Ukraine,
like any European democracy.
Had a right to join the open or
policy.
According to what he says in
this documentary, it seems that
he was perhaps more placating
Russia, saying don't worry,
Ukraine unlikely to join nato
anytime soon.
I think given that that was one
of many of more than a dozen
calls between Putin and other
leaders of nato countries in